okay so you're really excited about
rogue one but when you watch the trailer
you only recognize Darth Vader and this
lady who's weird name you can't remember
its Mon Mothma
here's the rundown on all the characters
you don't know yet
caution the spoilers are strong with
this one gen Ursa was born in captivity
while their parents were prisoners of
the separatist army they are freed for a
bit but then captured again when she's
15 years old as a result she becomes a
criminal badass like other Star Wars
protagonists Jin's daddy issues get her
recruited by the Rebel Alliance I
rebelled Galen or so is Jin's father and
also kind of the Elon Musk of the Star
Wars universe but instead of electric
cars his scientific specialty is Kyber
crystals Kyber crystals can be used to
magnify energy and are basically the
engine and light sabers the Empire
captures Galen because they want to use
his expertise to make something a little
bigger than a lightsaber understand
Orson Critic is the director of advanced
weapons research tasked with creating
the Death Star's super laser and he
needs help if he's going to get promoted
to a rank that people don't question a
second adult man wearing a cape on the
same space station Orson and Galen went
to school together and Orson uses that
connection to manipulate Galen into
taking a position researching Kyber
crystal as a renewable energy source
what is it renewing unbeknownst to Galen
it's actually powering a giant planet
killing laser
Segarra is the rebel pilot that flies
the earth so family to safety from
critic all those years ago and Jen still
sees him as a friend saw is the leader
of a resistance group on Jed Han known
as the partisans who become one of the
first cells to join the Rebel Alliance
during the Clone Wars he was subjected
to torture which may explain his or
footing okay I don't think the joke was
that bad
joining Jin on her mission is Captain
casseon and/or he's an intelligence
officer and the Alliance to restore the
Republic casseon is more on the
practical side to Jin's radical he
recruits for the rebels and apparently
deletes the memory of Imperial droids in
his free time which I consider to be a
handy hobby take c-3po s lack of a
social filter and love of statistics and
mix and Chewbacca's ability to rip
people's arms off and you got K to s o
aleikum Empire's Armed Forces this
imperial enforcer droid provides
protection and some comic relief I've
been looking sure rut in way is a blind
staff wielding warrior monk he was born
on Jed ha the home of the Jedi religion
and although he isn't force sensitive
himself is fiercely devoted to its
principles as we've seen fighting blind
is hard even for people with a high
midi-chlorian count but I would say this
guy's only disability is that he's a bit
too brave BAE's mal bus is turrets BFF
with a BFG like his bestie he grew up on
Jed ha but BAE's isn't the spiritual
type he's a freelance assassin with a
trademark heavy repeater cannon and he's
pretty good with other weapons too he's
a dude who kills people for a living and
something the Empire did has gotten him
pretty pissed off I wonder what that
could be
Bodie rook is the pilot of rogue one and
he has a lot in common with many of his
teammates like BAE's and sure rut he's
from Jeddah ha like Jan he's a little
hot-headed and like k2s oh he used to
work for the Empire
he was an imperial cargo pilot which
isn't quite glamorous it's kind of like
a truck driver but he's got his radio
communication game down
rogue some other character honorable
mentions are rebel admiral Rattus
generals draven and general merrick
partisan soldiers EDD Rio and benthic
two tubes guy gory and mercenary more
off rebel soldier POW and Ewing door
gunner bist in the frickin space monkey
this movie is going to be amazing
for more on your favorite comic books TV
shows and movies check out GameSpot
universe